hey youtubers is Charlie so early
Christmas present from the flash they
just dropped the trailer so I'm going to
ahead and play it then we'll talk about
it it's gonna be a rogue team-up the
three of us all want the same things to
see the flash what makes you think you
can stop in this time time for a real
war on Christmas
official census seriously how excited
are you for a mark hamill trickster
episode him coming back in a big way
along with captain cold and weather
wizard of course captain cold and
weather wizard would be around for like
a Christmas themed holiday episode where
it's supposed to be snowing mark hamill
Santa Claus makes me think a little bit
about Krampus just a twisted evil
version of the holiday clearly there's
got to be some other thing that they
want in this episode besides taking the
flash down but I think the berry
overcoming this challenge will be a big
hurdle that he has to jump over on his
way to defeating zoom he kind of got his
mojo back during the crossover episode
but there was so much going on in that
that there wasn't a lot of berry
character development it was mostly
about hawkman hawkgirl Vandal Savage
character development so next week on
the air on flash is just back to normal
I will be focusing on Flash characters
and it is gonna be a really big episode
if you remember last season they
actually teased the identity of the
reverse-flash but because we haven't
seen zoom in any of these trailers I'm
wondering if he's even in the episode I
feel like you can't do the mid-season
finale without him though
so even if the main action is this big
rogues revenge episode I still think
there'll be some zoom stuff going on in
the background and remember we have the
velocity-6 formula Harrison wells gonna
continue to iterate till he gets up to
velocity 9 a lot of you guys have told
me that you think that he's going to end
up giving that to his daughter Jessie
quick and that's how she becomes a
speedster or maybe Patty's gonna take
the formula I kind of want to think that
Jay Garrick is gonna take it in the
future too
not because he wants to but because he
feels there's no other choice it is
gonna be so meta though you have Luke
Skywalker trickster with Mark Martin's
lightsaber here hit the weather control
rod that they used to neutralize his
powers and you have Star Wars coming out
in less than two weeks
it's the perfect winter storm of fandoms
now I'm gonna talk a little bit about
wally west so just careful for spoilers
for the wally west character they've
already posted a bunch of images we know
kind of what's going on with his
character when he's going to appear but
just in case you don't to know anything
about that I'm just gonna say spoiler
warning so here we go wally west going
to appear in episode 9 now I know he's a
big guy like he's about the same size as
Grant Gustin so I do think that he is
another candidate for zoom but this
character here the earth 1 Wally West
that shows up is supposed to become Kid
Flash at a certain
so if it does go down that way in wally
west ends up being zoomed and i don't
think it's gonna be the wally west that
we meet on earth one his character is
mostly gonna be tied up with getting to
know his family the family that he maybe
didn't know about we really don't know
if he knew about Joe and iris we
definitely know that iris hasn't told Jo
yet so I'm hoping he just shows up on
their doorstep and Joe's like WTF who
are you supposed to be but here's the
big question do you think that Wally
West will get his powers from the
velocity-9 formula or through some other
experiment because in the comics that
way way back in the Silver Age comics he
got his powers the exact same way that
Barry did in the in the lab accident now
of course the TV show changed the Barry
Allen origin story there was a big Dark
Matter explosion he got hit by the
lightning yeah I became a fan of the
first season so I didn't know about the
flesh prior to that from the comics but
I learned about it quickly I was
explaining this to my friend the other
day I was just like it just made me feel
excited for whatever reason every time I
would watch the show I just was like
filled with a little more energy and
it's one of those shows so just it's a
feel-good show I think I had missed that
in a TV show for a while so it was cool
and to see that on top of some really
good acting performances I think I mean
everyone's kind of a favorite obviously
everyone wants to be the flash so that's
always a cool thing but everyone's
characters vary so much so that's why
it's it's really cool everyone so
layered and there's so many different
things that they can explore and I think
that's why hopefully the show will run
for a really long time because there's
so much that you can go deep into with
people so when you found out you had an
audition for the show yeah it was it was
funny part of me was like do I even want
to be on this show because I'm like I'm
happy just literally just watching this
show like I'm good but I had auditioned
for legends of tomorrow which is the
spin-off from arrow and flash that
they're doing and then that's the reason
why I started watching the flash was
because I thought I should do some
research on the universe and then yeah
so it was very unexpected and they said
hey they want you to audition for the
flash and I was like
they got have you heard of it I go yeah
I've heard of it so I guess it was more
so excitement than then pressure but yes
they did
yeah obviously the audition size were
secret and different names and whatnot
but they told me that I would be going
for Wally West and it was all very
secretive and exciting it yeah we know
now because of the television show that
you are irises brother enemy um in all
ways because Andrew said at a press
screening that your Joe son as well yeah
how exciting is not to go into the
family you know that Francie it's
Francine and Joe's sons yeah you know
yeah it's really cool I think as they
said as Andrew said it's it's always
that thing in a lot of shows where they
go this is my distant cousin that I've
never mentioned before and then all of a
sudden they're here it's really cool to
be to be a part of the family in the
most immediate way because then
obviously the connections are a lot
stronger and then family means even more
because it it's got a lot more depth
behind it so it's it's awesome and then
yeah I think it makes it more
interesting and it means that there's a
lot more that they can go into with the
show so they could go a number of
different ways we just have to keep our
eyes peeled I just I don't think that
Wally West is gonna get any flash powers
anytime really really soon I just think
they're gonna introduce him first and
he'll be a normal person for a little
while
but let me know in the comments what do
you guys want to see the most in this
big rogues revenge episode like are you
just are you hoping to say zoom find out
who he is I don't think that they're
gonna reveal who he is but it was
totally awesome if they did so what's
gonna happen is I have a Doctor Who
Christmas trailer to post there's some
more Game of Thrones that I'm gonna do
on Sunday maybe a Walking Dead bonus
video so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and there's a little bit of
weirdness going on on YouTube right now
but I think everything should be working
fine here's a few holiday bugs that are
working out in case you guys haven't
seen it I did a new legends of tomorrow
trailer video you can click here to
watch that and you can click here for
the arrow flash crossover episodes thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight